oh it's Halloween but I don't have a
costume [ __ ] what is this hey guys
and this is Halloween outfit ideas back
at it again what is this costume marina
what do you call my ideas Jesus Christ
who added these because if it's satire
it's [ __ ] beautiful you know like
what is that hey guys and welcome to
people today we're going to the cat nose
the god marina you've saved my Halloween
what's that what is what I said Sam oh
[Music]
you want to do the tutorial with me
Gunter oh that's great that's fantastic
I love marina Joyce you're a big marina
Joyce fine
I edit her videos for her you're the one
that edits my last explains the line you
don't have any arms and I do this in a
heart shape and I do this with glamorize
Rimmel London liquid eyeliner that's
perfect because I happen to have the
exact same brand somewhat lucky me
all right liquid eyeliner G hype is that
some kind of Halloween creepy edit or
does she actually edit that like that
like I can't tell G hi
okay well let's do that and then we can
speed it up and then I'm gonna kill
myself wait a minute wait a minute
that's super cute I wanted to I wanted
to I wanted to that's pretty good that's
pretty good and there you have it you
have a hot shape on your nose and there
you have it folks and there you have it
well thank you marina I said oh wow it's
really not good is it
it kind of like an IV hey smells so
strongly this one Oh
as you can see the hot shape and then
you want to do three whiskers either
side why are we still here
[Music]
just suffer
every night I can feel my leg and my arm
my fingers hey you want to do three
whiskers on the one side
I mean you did you did say three
whiskers on each side I don't know why
you have to tell me that twice three
whiskers either side I mean the whole
tutorial is kind of self-explanatory to
be honest and you want to do three
whiskers on the one side okay three
whiskers on the one side okay okay what
about me I want with my gosh
shut up I'm getting to you wait I can't
[ __ ] see like my view finder is so
tiny three of us kids on the other side
oh of course
three whiskers on the other side I feel
so stupid on this because like I I mix
up the easiest tutorial like most people
tell me every little detail I get a
problem so we did it right we did it
right well GABA look I almost call you
whiskers that be a cute name for you
[Music]
and then you want to do a line down from
your nose not copy me oh [ __ ] ah
goddammit
the instructions weren't clear enough
now I got a Hitler mustache and then you
color in black on the top of your lip
I'm gonna eat tasty fish give me that
finger daddy on that of your mama more
hey Gabba Gabba
mmm yeah yeah but let go and once you're
done you're ready to go as a cat for
Halloween [ __ ] yeah I'm ready as a cat
and so are you gobble let's go you
thought the video was over
no Tom your tits man I hope that you
enjoyed this look guys this is the
finished look and I'm going to be doing
an hour tutorial on all the clothes and
all the Halloween stuff that you should
wear so I hope that you enjoy this wait
wait wait a minute Michael what is this
what is that what is that what is this
huh what is this [ __ ] fashion this is
something you're not telling me
did you hurt your you're hanging out
with marina Joy's now you [ __ ] weirdo
stop hurting
it's like they're all still there
you feel it too don't you
I'm gonna make him give back our past
[Music]
this is now in ill intent to morena of
course check out our channel I leave a
link there description and I'll see you
next Tuesday
[Music]